the program of language is an open-ended
one and that we are dynamically caught
up in it but we our language that's what
distinguishes us from those who chirp
and Twitter and romp in the trees that
we are language and that language is
evolving it's changing and that in fact
what we call culture is nothing more
than a kind of shock wave trailing
behind the the forward edge of this
language making capacity because you
can't invent it before you can say it
you can't sell it before you can
describe it you can't do anything with
it until it exists as a lingua as a
command herbal set of syntactical
connections can you imagine a more
multi-purpose mutational adaptation 'el
well than being able to think clearly I
mean if a if a flatworm could think
clearly evolutionary horizons would open
before it or any other organism it's
like a super nonspecific immune response
you can handle any problem
yummy a problem I'm a thinker I can
handle it you know one of the things
that I think happened in the 60s that
supports my case in the wake of LSD you
see a tremendous enriching of language
endlessly sneered ad by those who don't
talk that way but you know it introduced
the notion of the vibe the ego trip
these are worthwhile concepts the bummer
the flashback these are linguistic
pearls that you know crystallized out of
that experience the I believe that the
psychedelics are working at the cultural
level to promote language but also to
its it's not simply a linear enriching
of language
there's also something
biologically that language is actually
gaining in the vertical dimension in its
behold ability when you listen to my
voice if you understand what I'm saying
it's because my incoming words cause you
to go to your dictionary and look them
up one by one and if your dictionary is
pretty close to my dictionary we will
understand each other but the whole act
of communication depends on this
assumption that the dictionaries are the
same if they're not the same then you
will not understand me if on the other
hand I could make you see what I mean
this is not a culturally conditioned
avenue of information transfer you don't
have to learn English to look at an
English woman it's easy you just do it
it's at the biological level and so this
is I think in terms of consciousness
expansion you say well it's good it as a
general notion but what direction is it
moving it's moving in the direction of
literally a clarifying of language a
clarifying of language into something
that can be beheld and it's an arrow
toward a greater domain of existential
validity that each of us can can move in
we need to communicate we need to find
out who we are each of us individually
and then we need to tell each other the
whole dominator style of unstoned
culture engineering is ego that's what
happens when you don't take psychedelic
drug as a culture ego flows in that's
what was happening on the plains of
Africa every Saturday night everybody
was getting loaded and boundaries were
dissolving the boundary of the
assumption of the uniqueness of the
individual they were taking these things
and they were having wrote group sex
basically these were the two things it's
clear because of the quality of
psilocybin that it actually at at
mid-range doses causes arousal you see
at very low doses it increases visual
acuity therefore you're hunting improves
there for you and your progeny are more
successful and then it's slightly higher
doses
everybody's horny and there's a lot of
activity in the group and and partying
at higher doses then that turns into
religion and you just slam to the floor
of the cave you know so it's this 3-step
thing which plays on our basic needs to
drive us into a deeper and deeper
relationship with this with this mystery
and it's such a it's such a huge idea
that this is what we are that this is so
fundamental that this isn't just some
curiosity of you know hedonic West Coast
so forth and so on
but that it is in fact central to
understanding and defining humaneness
and to trying to grab some of the
controls of this sinking submarine of a
planet and get it back up to the surface
long enough for us to all climb in a
rowboat and to make our way somewhere
[Music]